yep question you're talking about here
around 300 million people so why is
quietiy group your size which is America
it really paid do you think the right
and left can talk to each other you
think they speak the same language right
you see of that fragmenting occurring
and they really are not only are they
speaking different languages they're
they really are speaking different
languages it's the right way of thinking
about it yes it's very very dangerous
you know I think the u.s. worked for a
long time first of all because it didn't
always have 300 million people it's a
lot of people to put under one umbrella
now the utility of the American system
is that it is a hierarchy right there's
individuals families towns states
underneath a somewhat loose federal
structure and that's sort of so it's not
a it's not a monolith where everyone has
to speak precisely the same language
it's got some flexibility built into its
structure because it's it's come it's
it's formulated in two components which
have a certain amount of autonomy and so
far that's worked sufficiently well
whether it will contend it will probably
continue to work I mean the Americans
are very very robust people and they've
gone through things that are analogous
to what they're going through now many
times god only knows right but but it's
very dangerous thing to presume that the
Americans are down for the count because
they have an uncanny ability to rise out
from mash is even stronger than they
were before but you can certainly see
the danger lurking Europe that's that's
a different thing like I think the
European state is doomed because I think
it grew too fast and it severed the
connection between like there's not the
proper hierarchy of identification so
and people are saying wait Brussels like
who the hell are you guys why are you
making decisions for us and we don't
agree with your decisions and like are
you sure that Greece and Germany can be
in the same place because that's by no
means self-evident right the Germans
aren't very happy about it
and the Greeks aren't very happy about
it and one of the rules for making an
organization is that it's a lot easier
to make a functional or
organization worse than it is to make a
dysfunctional organization better and so
you might say well you've got Germany
and France and England well let's say
Germany and France powerhouses
especially Germany they can afford to
bring Greece in well maybe but there's
no evidence that they can afford it so I
mean Greece is unbelievably corrupt no
one pays their income tax that's a big
problem right and bringing them in to a
union at a high order has no effect
whatsoever on the micro behaviors and
the thing is the micro behaviors have to
be rectified and no one really knows how
to do that how do you stop a country
where people don't pay their taxes from
how do you stop people from not paying
their taxes why do we pay our taxes who
knows we could just all of a sudden
decide not to you know and the
government wouldn't have the resources
to run around gathering them all up for
one reason or another it's become
customary for people in functional
Western democracies to pay their taxes
but why who knows it would have been way
easier for us just to do what the Greeks
did and pretend to pay them you know so
they're too big I think and so the
people on the right is saying back to
the nation like I understand why they're
doing that but but the danger is the
nation will subordinate the individual
and I do see it as another example of
safe spaces
it's just scales different so and that's
why I think that the proper antidote to
that to both the chaos on the left and
the order on the right roughly speaking
is to walk the proper line in the middle
and when did we better do that because
things are not things are too chaotic at
the moment so it's not good maybe it's
really good
that's possible but we're in a state
where I really believe we're in a state
where things could go any number of ways
and there's no there's no predicting it
so and I've never felt that you know I
mean I lived in the 80s and you know
political correctness rose up in the 90s
as well and I can remember a lot of what
happened in the early 70s with the oil
crisis and all that so there were times
when things were
shaky but they weren't shaky the way
they are now they're an internal
shakiness rather than something that was
a threat that was seem to be imposed
from the outside and that's different
and and it's it's it is associated with
with this intellectual war that's going
on with post-modernism and new Marxism
and all of that as well so